[Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  [Music]  welcome to the new icarly  we'll help however we can i'm really  glad to hear you say that  damn it here we go  people are weirdly loving this i don't  think this is how you do it  this is your moment to shine you need to  be a trailblazer like an effortless  trailblazer like i just got out of bed  was all  oops i just blazed a trail hot wings hot  cheetos hot pretzels and hot beers  that's the last time i listened to guy  fieri i am in no place to date  freddy i put your warm milk in your  thermos next to your bed  so we done here  this is not how i imagined my life the  garlic  maybe you just need some arm candy of  your own and i have the perfect guy  yeah we're done  [Music]  you think you can shoot me using that  filter that makes my cheekbones all  like an alien a sexy alien  [Music]  you